the Joe Rogan experience you're not a
lot of Russell's without if you have
braces in wrestling in high school
you're not allowed to compete unless you
have Amalfi's it's like a new rule that
should they should this shouldn't be a
lot of compete without mouthpieces
anyway you want to [ __ ] up your lips
yeah even now when I'm Russell and I
bite down when I'm shooting sometimes
and I get my jaw like smash against my
teeth like so much it's my teeth that
way yeah it's not good now I wear
melfi's always I always wear a cup too
and I work up cuz I got needing the dick
once my dick was bleeding yeah again my
friend Scott Epstein Einstein same dude
he goes past my garden it's just an
accident slammed his knee into my dick
flattened my dick right on the deck it's
just sometimes it happens where it's
like you Zig they zag pop and when I
took my jock off at the end of rolling
there was blood and my jockstrap I'm
like oh no where you guys drilling we
gonna live cuz view no really live we're
going live it's just accident it was
just an accident it's just [ __ ] that
happens yeah
but it was if I had it now I wear one of
those diamond MMA cups you ever [ __ ]
with those are the compression shorts so
here's my thing with those guys and I
was gonna say something earlier but I
didn't want to I just don't think one
cup fits all I just can't see your dicks
too big
I understand al Joe my my crotch the
diver cup is too big for my crotch man
it changes it like chase not comfortable
and I tried it I was like do maybe I'm
wearing it wrong I tried it upside down
to just be making different sizes they
told me you know dude is one size fits
all I'm like dude this just doesn't make
any sense
wait a minute wait a minute what Frank
ah no Francis and gone oh and Henry
cejudo cop get in the [ __ ] that's what
they told me what you say that's not
even possible
yeah they thought they'd come up to like
the fight advantage I actually seen him
in a Chicago I'm in Chicago again like
handing out like samples and stuff and
he asked me like how did you like the
cup I'm like yeah I don't want to be a
dick I don't like being a mean guy but
you asking me this question I feel like
I got to tell you the truth my man just
didn't like it he's like I what was
wrong with it tell me one size just
doesn't fit all I just was that's why
like it just doesn't fit it's too big
it's too big down there you don't want
something that's comfortable so you
could kick and leg squeeze your legs
together and nah man that's just gonna
be crushing my sac all over the place
mmm I get it well for me it fits perfect
but I get it
everybody's a small guy different sized
junk area and if you have fatter thighs
too right like were like dudes with like
you know giant like Shawn Jordan guys a
giant fake-ass legs like how you gonna
get you know yeah it's gonna rub against
it but does the compression shorts would
help with that because that's the whole
idea is that instead of like the way
everybody used to wear it was just like
a jockstrap right you'd have a cup in
the jockstrap and it kind of floated
around like I'm not gonna talk about no
turn when I got kicked in the balls once
and my cup slammed into my nut ah and I
was convinced I was convinced my balls
were useless after that cuz my [ __ ]
swole up like 2 times the size that
should have been and it was all purple
and I was like I broke my balls did you
have to get it drained or did just like
a dummy I was 18 I didn't do it to make
sure it worked once it still work - Mike
we're good I broke my dick
I waited that not upbeat often just to
make sure it works we're good we're good
that's funny man that was like chicken
embryos in my toilet bowl my face under
like it just came out pissed came out
bloody - I pissed blood for a couple
days that's the worst pissing blood well
I knew it was all just dick blood I was
just like the moment I feel like any
sort of infection or it feels like it's
sore it didn't hurt so it's like I'm not
gonna be nervous I'm gonna treat it like
my nose I'm like I don't want my nose to
fall off either but if my nose is bloody
I don't freak out so I didn't want to
freak out if my dick was bloody
I don't like let me just treat it like
it's a normal thing just don't don't
freak out and it was fine
it's like ignore the lion in the room
keep moving if I'm pissing blood I'm
freaking the [ __ ] out no I was a little
freaking out it wasn't like I was not
nervous at all but I was trying to
rationalize and I'm saying okay this is
no different than my nose if my nose was
bleeding right now and I ran to the
hospital freaking the [ __ ] out I'd be a
[ __ ]
right right your nose bloody
a lot you gotta need that for some
things you definitely do I definitely
wasn't I mean I wasn't ignoring it I was
like the moment it feels like if my nose
is infected I probably walk it off but
if my dick is in fact that I am going
straight to the ER
[Applause]